the government has as much of a right to
control what I as an adult put into my
body as it does what I put into my mind
it's none of their business
[Music]
when I was appointed to the bench by
Governor Beebe nation at the end of 1983
I was still a drug warrior you know I'd
been a member of Navy jag actually
writing charge sheets against my fellow
shipmates from the Naval Air Station in
Guam who had been a run afoul of various
laws certainly including drug laws I was
a criminal defense attorney representing
other people from different stations who
were charged with drug offenses among
others and then I was a federal
prosecutor for several years in Los
Angeles in fact I held the record for
the largest drug prosecution in the
Central District of California back in
1978
75 kilos a heroin 160 pounds which was
and is a whole lot of heroin does anyone
have a concept of what the drug
prosecution record is today in the
Central District of California 18 tons
of cocaine in one place actually in
Sylmar so you begin to look at your own
experience you look at what's going on
in your own courtroom you're churning
low-level drug offenders through the
system for no good purpose whatsoever
you are arresting some even high-level
dealers and if you do that does that
mean that heroin is no longer available
on the streets of Santa Ana or wherever
no it doesn't mean that at all it just
means that somebody else sees that as an
employment opportunity and I came to the
realization at that time and that
realization has to be understood by
others the tougher we get with regard to
drug crime literally the softer we get
with regard to the prosecution of
everything else in 1990 we were only
half is successful in prosecuting
homicides countrywide as we had been in
1980 why well because the Reagan
administration once again had ratcheted
up the war on drugs so we were using all
of these prosecutorial resources to
prosecute nonviolent drug offenders such
that robbers rapers and murderers were
being able to skate with regard to their
charges because we didn't devote those
resources for that offense
who
winning today with regard to this failed
policy and I have six groups travel
along with me and see if you agree the
first group obviously are the drug lords
big-time drug dealers they're making
hundreds of millions billions of dollars
every year tax-free by the way and
they're clearly winning the number two
group of people that are winning are
those in juvenile gangs pretty much
every juvenile gang we have in our
country gets its primary source of
funding for the sale of the illegal
drugs and now they're using it as a
recruiting tool to bring more children
into this lifestyle because they too can
be part of the action and make some
money number three group of people that
are winning are basically those in law
enforcement that are making big-time
government money to fight against the
first two groups and I'm not pointing
the finger at law enforcement they
haven't failed us anymore for the war on
drugs than Eliot Ness failed us with
regard to the war on alcohol but it's
the system but nevertheless they're
bureaucracies have expanded their
amounts of money and their power have
all expanded as well they're winning
fourth group of people are the
politicians that basically talk tough
with regard to the war on drugs not
smart but they get elected and
re-elected by talking tough of course
it's our fault because we continue to
elect them but they come out ahead
number five groups are those in the
private sector to make money because of
increased crime who might that be
obviously the people that build prisons
enormous Lee lucrative occupation people
that staff prisons in the state of
California the prison guards union is
the strongest political lobby group we
have they're winning and of course
they're laughing at us and the sixth
group of people that are winning are the
terrorist organizations of the world you
look at any terrorist organization from
Osama bin Laden or anywhere else the
primary source of funding is drug money
it's the sale of illegal drugs to the
degree that I say that drug prohibition
is the Golden Goose of terrorism and if
our government really wanted to do
something damaging to terrorist groups
around the world they would take the one
step that would do that repeal drug
prohibition who is losing everybody else
I've been speaking actively against our
nation's drug policy since 1992 the
first national TV show I was on
they basically stacked it with a lot of
parents of drug drug problems for their
kids and the first question I got was
why are you trying to kill my son and it
kind of got worse from there that
doesn't happen anymore people are
beginning to understand there is an
initiative now in California to treat
marijuana like alcohol for adults what
would happen if this were to pass well
six things the first five demonstrably
beneficial then we'll talk about the
sixth the first thing that would happen
is we in the state of California as
taxpayers literally could save hundreds
of millions of dollars per year if not a
billion dollars a year that now we
actually spend in a futile effort to try
to eradicate marijuana as well as to
incarcerate prosecute and incarcerate
nonviolent marijuana offenders and of
course you can tell how successful we
are in Marin the eradication of
marijuana because it's still the largest
cash crop in the state of California
number two is grapes by the way if you
care so that's a billion dollars or so
that we can save number two we could tax
the silly stuff and generate revenue
according to the head the chair of the
State Board of Equalization about 1.3
billion dollars every year so now that's
about a two point three billion dollar
shift in the budget deficit for the
state of California you'd think somebody
would notice but the third thing Trump's
the first two and that is we would make
marijuana less available for children
than it is today that is something that
really does deserve a great deal of
attention number for the entire hemp
industry could be revitalized goes back
thousands of years to the degree that in
ancient Greek the word canvas and
cannabis were synonymous they were the
same word and we have simply sorted that
entire really important industrial
purpose we do have our merchants using
hemp today and by the way hemp you know
is just the stalk of the marijuana plant
it has no mind altering properties
whatsoever but it can be used for all
kinds of really beneficial purposes so
now our merchants import the raw
material from those radical countries
like Canada and England for heaven's
sake penalizing ourselves in our own
agricultural purposes you'd think that
we could somehow realize what's going on
because the the Canadian hemp field is
worth you know got a billion dollars a
year and the fifth thing this entire
medical marijuana issue would pretty
much dissolve and hooray for that it
would get some control on it regulated
control it tax it and bring it back
under the law
then there's the six thing what's that
going to do to marijuana usage by adults
and any economist of course will tell
you that's really pretty simple it will
increase marijuana use by adults all
things being equal but all things are
not going to be equal will probably soon
start experiencing the what I call the
Holland effect because in Holland
anybody sixteen years of age or older
can go to a coffee house and can get
coffee and sandwiches and tea and also
marijuana and hashish the Minister of
Health of Holland held a press
conference not all that long ago and
said we in our country have only half
the marijuana consumption per capita as
you do in the United States of America
both for adults and for teenagers
wait a minute you hear that both for
adults and for teenagers then went on to
explain why you know what he said he
said we have succeeded in making pot
boring people that are supporting the
status quo are on the wrong side of
history just like the people that the
Billy Sunday's and and the Anslinger's
and the rest who supported alcohol
prohibition were on the wrong side of
history
it's just a question of when and then I
guarantee anyone who will listen that
two years after we change away from this
failed and hopeless policy everybody
will join arms look back astonished
aghast that we could have perpetuated
such a failed system for so long the
best thing I can do for my country is to
help us repeal drug prohibition it's the
most patriotic thing that I'm able to
and we're going to be successful in some
engines when you call me
you
[Music]